[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ما يحدث في اسرائيل مثير القلق
ويستحق المتابعه معظم الجمهور العربي توقف
عن متابعه الشان الاسرائيلي لمده سنوات في
تقدير من حوالي 15 سنه ببساطه لان
الاهتمام بالشكل الاسرائيلي كان مبني على
فرديه واحده هذه الفرديه الواحده الاساسيه
هو انه هناك طيارات مختلفه في اسرائيل
اليسار المعتدل واليمين المتشدد وانه اذا
جاءت حكومه يا ساريه معتدله في اسرائيل
يمكن التفاوض مع علي حقوق الفلسطينيين
واعاده الاراضي للسوريين وتحريك عمليه
السلام ولكن بعد سنوات من المتابعه
والاهتمام ادرك الكثير من المتابعين العرب
وغير العرب ان هذا وهم وانه اذا جاءت
حكومه يا ساريه او حكومه يمنيه لن يتغير
شيء لان المساله مرتبطه بتوازن القوى اللي
بيميل بشكل هائل للاسرائيليين وبالتالي لن
يحصل العرب على حقوقهم مهما تغيرت
ومات
فطر الحماس
للمتابعه الشان الاسرائيلي خصوصا في
السنوات الاخيره اللي يسيطر فيها بنيامين
نتنياهو القطب اليمني المتشدد جدا على
السلطه في اسرائيل من 2009 والى الان لكن
ما يحدث في اسرائيل هذه الايام بيعيد
الاهتمام بالشان الاسرائيلي لان ما يحدث
شيء استثنائي لم يحدث من قبل وبيثير قلق
الشرق والغرب يثير قلق الجميع عشان نفهم
ايه اللي بيحصل في اسرائيل تعالوا نفهم
القصه الكبيره وابسط فهمه للقصه الكبيره
ان احنا ناخذها من زاويه نترياه لان
نتنياهو هو بطل كل هذه القصه
بنيامين نتنياهو هو اهم شخصيه سياسيه في
اسرائيل في السنوات الاخيره وصل السلطه
اول مره من سنه 96 حتى
1999 ثم ابتعد عن الساحه السياسيه ثم وصل
مره اخرى في 2009 وظل في السلطه حتى مايو
2021 وبالتالي حكم 15 سنه منهم 12 سنه
متصله ليكون بذلك اطول سياسي يبقى في منصب
رئيس الوزراء في تاريخ دوله الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه
في سنوات الطويله تورط في مجموعه من
العباءات الكثيره مع خصومه اللي عاوزينه
يعني يذهب من الحياه السياسيه حتى يحل
محله من ناحيه وتورط في قضايا اخرى كثيره
واصبح ملاحق في القضاء بثلاثهم الرشوه
والاحتيال وخيانه الامانه وعلى الارجح اذا
يعني صارت الامور في مسارتها هو هيل-
هيقضي بقيه حياته السياسيه وعنده 73 سنه
هيقضي بقيه حياته في السجن وليس في موقع
رئيس الوزراء او المعارضه
الحياه السياسيه في السنوات الاخيره في
اسرائيل اصبحت منقسمه الى معسكريين ليس
يمين ويسار كما كان الحال في السنوات
الماضيه ولكن معسكر المؤيدين لنتنياهو
ومعسكر الرافدين والمعارضين لنتنياهم
الخلاف على نتنياهو وسياساته ادى الى فوضى
سياسيه في اسرائيل في السنوات الاخيره
وتحديدا من 2019 والى الان وحصلت فيها خمس
انتخابات المفروض الانتخابات دي بتحصل مره
كل اربع سنين لا في الاقل من اربع سنين
حصلت خمس انتخابات ودائما نتنياهو الشخصيه
المسيطره على المشهد السياسي الاسرائيلي
الخلاصه انه نتيجه تورطه في قضايا فساد
نتيجه خلافاته الكثيره مع سياسيين
اسرائيليين كثيرين على مدار سنوات تحالف
خصومه ضده وقرروا عدم التحالف معه
وبالتالي عجز عن تشكيل اغلبيه في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي خرج من السلطه في
مايو 2021
وتشكلت اكثر من حكومه من خصومه
وسموا نفسهم حكومه التغيير لكن لان
بنيامين يتنياهو يظله هو اهم شخصيه سياسيه
في اسرائيل فقد نجح للعوده للسلطه مره
اخرى بعد فاصل قصير لكن يعود للسلطه ليه
وازاي هو ده موضوع حلقتنا هو عاوز يرجع
للسلطه ولو هدف اساسي مختلف هذه المره هذه
المره السادسه التي يعود فيها الى السلطه
الهدف الاساسي انه ينجو من مصيره المظلم
المحتوم بالذهاب الى السجن ازاي ممكن
السلطه تساعده للهرب تساعده على الهرب من
قضاء يعني بقيه حياته في السجن ببساطه هو
حسبته كالتالي
الملاحقه القضائيه سوف تظل موجوده وهو
خارج وهو في السلطه وهو خارج السلطه لانه
نظريا القانون
لن يتوقف عن ملاحقته اذا كان رئيسا
للوزراء هذا لن يحمي نظريا ولم يعطيه
حصانه لكن عمليا اذا كان خارج السلطه فمن
المؤكد ان الاحتمالات كبيره جدا ان يدانو
ان يذهب الى السجن لكن اذا دخل الى السلطه
فسوف تكون لديه في اضعف الاحوال قدره على
المناوره وربما التحايل بحيث ينجو من
احكام القضاء ازاي ده ممكن يتم ده بدا
واضحا جدا في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه
واضح ان التصور انه هيتم اغلى مجموعه من
الاجراءات التي تسعى في نهايه المطاف الى
اعطائه حصانه مثلا يغيروا المحامي العام
ويعينه شخص اخر يكون اكثر تعاطفا معهم
يقوموا بتغيير اصلا
ساعات التي وفقا لها يمكن ان تتم ادانته
هو استعان ب همم وزير عدل من حلفاؤه ووزير
العدل ده اطلق برنامج كبير لاصلاح القضاء
كله
ويسعى يعني همم
من خلال هذه الدعوه البراقه
اللي بيقول ان اهدافها دعمت ديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل انه يمنح الكنيسه القدره على
تعليق احكام المحكمه العليا وانه يتمكن
السياسيون من تعيين القضاه في المحكمه
العليا وبالتالي يستطيع السيطره على
المحكمه العليا لو ما كانش عندك فكره عن
الحياه السياسيه في اسرائيل احب اقول لك
ان المساله ببساطه انه برغم ان اسرائيل
دوله عنصريه ودوله ابارتايت ودوله احتلال
لكن الاسرائيلي فيما بينهم دوله ديمقراطيه
ولا دوله قانون الكنيسه اللي هو عباره عن
البرلمان الاسرائيلي والمكون من 120 مقعد
ويسيطر عليه الحزب او الائتلاف الحاكم
وبالتالي الاختلاف الحاكم ده بيشكل
الحكومه ما يعني ان الحزب اللي بيفوز في
الانتخابات او الاحزاب اللي بتفوز في
الانتخابات بتسيطر على السلطه التنفيذيه
تسيطر على السلطه التشريعيه لفتره من
الزمن اللي بيحافظ على استقلاله هو القضاء
وده الامر مزعج جدا لنتنياهو يعني حلفاؤه
لعده اسباب ما يهمون في هذه الحلقه انه
مصائبهم يعني في مهب الريح اذا ضل القضاء
مستقلا
لكن عموما دي مش موضوعنا النهارده هو هدفه
النهائي من الاصول الى السلطه حمايه نفسه
فهذا هو الهدف ازاي يصل الى السلطه بعد ان
تخلى عنه حلفاؤه او خصومه او سياسيين
الاساسيين على الساحه الاسرائيليه لم يكن
له من حل الا بالتحالف مع جماعات هامشيه
جماعات بالغه التطرف دينيا وقوميا هو كان
بيصفها فيما مضى بانها لا تصلح للعمل
للسياسه لانها بالغت التطرف دينيه وقوميه
لكن اصبحوا هم الملاذقن الاخير بالنسبه
لهم نجح في الانتخابات الماضيه في نوفمبر
الماضي وفي تشكيل الحكومه بعد ان حصل على
الاغلبيه في الكنيسه بنت تحالف مع هذه
الجامعات اديكم فكره سريعه حتى تستقيم
الامور
في احزاب كثيره في اسرائيل
ونتيجه ان في احزاب كثيره في اسرائيل وفي
حياه سياسيه غنيه وحيه يعني لم يحدث ابدا
ان فيه اي حزب من سنه 48 فيما اعتقد يعني
حصل على اغلبيه مطلقه وشكل الحكومه من اول
مره الحزب عاده بيعجز عن انه يجيب
الاغلبيه المطلقه مهمه 120 يبقى الاغلبيه
المطلقه من 61 مقعد في الكنيست فما اعلى
الاحزاب عاده بتجيب اللي بتنجح بتجيب عدد
كبير تجيب 30 40 مقعد وبتضطر علشان توصل
للاغلبيه المطلقه انها تتحالف مع احزاب
اخرى وبالتالي فكره تكوين التلافات عشان
يقدروا يحصلوا على الاغلبيه المطلقه في
الكنيسه وبالتالي يشكل الحكومه مقروف جدا
في اسرائيل
لكن اللي كان بيحصل دائما اللي نتنياهو في
السنوات ال 15 اللي حكم فيها وغيره من
رؤساء مجلس الوزراء بيجيب عدد كبير من
المقاعد وبالتالي بيتم التكليفه بتشكيل
الحكومه ولانه ما عندوش الاغلبيه المطلقه
فبيبدا في مفاوضات بطنيه مع حساب المختلفه
عشان يوصلوا الى نسبه ال61 مقعد فما فوق
ده كان عاده ما احزاب معروفه وليها برامج
همم مالوفه وبينتموا الى ما يسمى
بالمينسترين يعني
احزاب بتلعب بقواعد اللعبه من النادر اللي
كان يسيطر على الموقف احزاب بالغه التطرف
كما حدث في انتخابات نوفمبر 2022 لكن بسبب
مقاطعه نتنياهو اضطر الى ان يلج اليهم
وبالفعل نجح في تشكيل الحكومه بعد ان امن
اغلبيه مطلقه في الكنيسه اعتقد 64 صوت
ولكن على اكتاف مجموعه من اكثر اليهود
تطرفا وخطوره طب وماذا يترتب على ذلك
ببساطه هذه الجماعات اشهدتها عشان ديتها
المعلنه هي تم الضفه الغربيه هدم المسجد
الاقصى طرد العرب داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه الاراضي اللي بيعتبروها اراضي
اسرائيليه
عشان تعرفوا خطوره الموقف تعال نشوف
المجموعه اللي تالف معها نتنياهو وعشان
نعرف المجموعه دي يعني هنحتاج ان احنا
نفهم المشهد الداخلي كله في اسرائيل وده
يحتاج الى يعني وقتا طويل جدا لكن باختصار
تركيز على الجامعات الدينيه
وتحديدا الجامعات الدينيه اللي هي عندها
اجندات سياسيه خطيره هو تحلف مع نوعين من
الجماعات الدينيه وقبل ما اكمل انا بدين
بالشكر لصديق الدكتور احمد فؤاد استاذ
اللغه العبريه والخبير في شان الاسرائيلي
اللي ساعدني في فهم كثير من التفاصيل التي
كانت التي كان يصعب علي ان افهمها دون
العوده الى خبير يعني
نتنياهو تحالف مع نوعين من الجامعات
الدينيه جامعات نقدر نسميها كده جامعات
السلفيه اليهوديه ودي جماعه ما عندهاش
اهتمام كبير بالسياسه لكن كل ما يعنيهم هو
تطبيق
الشرائع الدينيه في الحياه اليوميه
اليهوديه
بيمثلهم دلوقتي من
الكنيست ومن تحالف مع نتنياهو بيمثلوا
بحزب شاس وحزب يهوده فاتوره 11 مقعد
ويهوده ترى مقعدين دول اهتمامهم اكثر
بالجوانب الدينيه يعني عاوزين مقابل
تحالفهم معنى نتنياهو انه يعطي للشعائر
الدينيه والطابع اليهودي اهتمام اكبر
يديهم مخصصات ماليه اكبر لدعم مدارسهم
الدينيه يساعدهم في تطبيق اولوياتهم
الدنيا زي تعطيل الحياه يوم السبت همم عدم
وجود محلات مفتوحه عدم وجود مواصلات عامه
يتم الفصل ما بين الذكور والاناث قدر
الامكان في الاماكن العامه عدم
تدعيم فكره استثناء من يدرس التلمود من
الخدمه العسكريه ما يدرسوما ما يخدموش في
الجيش
تدريس التلمود والتوراه في المدارس
العاديه او المدارس العلمانيه اعفاء دارسي
التلمود والتوراه من
دراسه الانجليزي والماس والساينس تضيع وقت
يعني اجن الاهتمام اكثر ان هم يكون عندهم
القول النهائي في الشعائر الحياه اليوميه
الاكل والشرب والدفن والجنائز والزواج الى
اخرهم بل يهمهم وده اللي ما يهمناش
لكن الفصيل الثاني اللي تحالف معاناه
المياه وعنده
تهمنا لانها خطيره جدا هو ما يسمى بائتلاف
الصهيونيه الدينيه ودول عباره عن ثلاث
احزاب الحزب الاولاني هو حزب القوه
اليهودي
اللي اصبح اسم مشهور في الاعلام العربي في
الاسابيع الماضيه والاتحاد
القوميريتش وحزب نوعان بزعامه ابي معوز
الثلاثه دول حصلوا على 14 مقعد وبالتالي
كان لهم دور مهم جدا في انه يمنحوا
الاغلبيه المطلوبه حتى يتمكن نتنياهو من
تشكيل الحكومه والعوده الى السلطه
في مقابل هذا الدعم حصلوا على وعود مكتوبه
وامنوها لانهم لا يثق في بنيامين نتنياهو
هو الراجل عنده تاريخ طويل انه يرضي
الناخبين ويرضوا شركاؤه وبعد كده يعمل
اللي يراه مناسبا حين يصل الى السلطه
فقالوا له نتفق بشكل رجعه لك فيه عن
ضمانات معينه ومن بين الضمانات دي ان هذه
الاحزاب والرؤسائها يحصلوا على مقاعد
يحصلوا على وزارات حقائب بالغه التاثير في
الحياه الاسرائيليه الداخليه والخارجيه
مثلا حزب القول اليهودي او القوه اليهوديه
بسامه اثمار بن غفير حصل على وزاره الامن
القومي يعني يشرف على البوليس داخل
اسرائيل ويشرف على البوليس اللي اسمه حرس
الحدود في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
حزب الاتحاد القومي بزعامه بيت سلائيل
سامي تريتش هيحصل سامو تريتش سامو تريتش
في مقابل دعمه ليله نياهو على وزاره
الماليه وهي مهمه في اي حكومه جدا
وبالاضافه الى وزاره جديده استحدثوها
اسمها وزير في وزاره الدفاع
باختصار بدل ما كانت وزاره الدفاع بتشرف
على المستوطنات
والاداره المدنيه للاراضي المحتله في
الضفه الغربيه هو سوف يشرف على الاداره
المدنيه هناك
سلموا اللي مش عارف ايه مفتاح القرار زي
ما بيقولوا في المثل المصري لان هو مستوطن
متطرف فسوف يشرف على حركه الاستيطان ضمن
مهامه في الوزاره الجديده حزب نوعان وده
اصغر هذه الاحزاب المنضمه في اختلاف
الصهيونيه الدينيه ابي ناعوس هيبقى نائب
وزير في مكتب لكنه سوف يشرف على الانشطه
في وزاره التعليم الاسرائيليه التعليم في
اسرائيل في المناهج العاديه وفي جانب
انشطه الشركات اللي بتحصل اللي بتمنح منح
للطلبه الندوات الانشطه الخارجيه كلها هو
سوف يشرف عليها فكانه وزيرا للانشطه في
وزاره التعليم
طيب ما خطوره ذلك خطوره ذلك ان دول اجندهم
باختصار زي ما قلت لحضراتكم هي اقامه
الدوله دينيه
دوله يهوديه فقط بيعتبروا اليهو العرب ليس
لهم حقوق بل خونه ويجب طردهم هدم المسجد
الاقصى وتغييره هويته وضم الضفه الغربيه
تعالوا علشان تشوفوا خطوره التحالف مع هذه
الشخصيات التي كانت هامشيه واللي كان
نتنياهو بيقول انها لا تصلح للعمل السياسي
قبل ذلك من اسابيع او شهور قليله لكنه
اضطر للتحالف معهم خدمه لهدفه الاساسي
الوصول الى السلطه وتامين مصالحه ناخذ
اثمار من غفير اللي هو اشهر الامثله مر بن
غفير تقدر تلخص افكاره في كلمتين اثنين
مقير كهانه هو من اتباع ماركانا
ده حاخام يهودي متطرف متطرف بتعبيري انا
ده يعني
الصك الرسمي للحكومه الاسرائيليه
والحكومات الغربيه وعلى راسها الولايات
المتحده
اسرائيل اعتبرته جماعه ارهابيه والولايات
المتحده اعتبارته جماعه ارهابيه ده قتل
سنه 90 واغتالوا مصري امريكي اسمه سيد
نصير وده لقصه طويله اشرنا اليها في سلسله
الحلقات اللي استضافت فيها الدكتوره هبه
جمال الدين عن الابراهيميه استاذنكم ان
تعودوا اليها وسوف اضع لكم روابتها على كل
حال الراجل ده وكيل سنه 90 وجماعته حظرت
باعتبارها جماعه ارهابيه سنه 94 في
اسرائيل وهي جماعه ارهابيه على قوائم
الجماعات الارهابيه والمنظمات الارهابيه
في عدد من الدول الغربيه وعلى رسائل
الولايات المتحده هو بيعتبر نفسه
يعني متحدث باسم هذه الجماعه
المحظوره يعني
وافكار وهي افكار مائير كهانه اللي هي
اقامه دوله يهوديه فقط وطرد العرب وتهويد
الاماكن المقدسه وطبعا في كل الاحوال هو
بيسعى الى
التوسع في المستوطنات اتمرن غفير هو عباره
عن محامي يعني عامله محامي
والقضايا الاساسيه اللي بيتولاها هي
الدفاع عن المستوطنين اللي بيعتادوا على
العرب وبيحاولوا اكبرهم على الخروج من
المنازلهم واحده من القضايا الشهيره مثلا
لتولى كانت في 2006 هو الدفاع عن شبين
اسرائيليين احرقوا منزل فلسطيني فكانت
النتيجه انه حرق الرجل وزوجته وطفلهما في
هذا الحريق
القضاء الاسرائيلي نفسه ادانه 50 مره او
اتهموا 50 مره بتهم نشر الكراهيه ودعم
جماعه ارهابيه والترويج الافكار عنصريه
وايدين في ال 50 مره دول اربع مرات بشكل
قاطع منهم مره في سنه 2007 لانه كان بيحمل
شعارات بتقول انه اطرده العدو العربي من
اسرائيل
اعضاء الكنيست العرب طابور خامس مائير
كهان كان على حق طيب
الراجل ده عنده ابطال اخرين غير ما يركانه
وبيعلق صورهم باعتبارهم ابطال ابطال زينين
يعني مثلا زي باروخ جولد شتاين فاكرين
حضراتكم بالهشتاين ده اليهودي المتطرف
اللي قتل 29 فلسطين في الخليل في مسجد في
الخليل اثناء صلاتهم
سنه 1994
عنده سجل مخيف جدا يعني لكن على كل
الاحوال الراجل ده حاول يبيض صورته بحيث
يكون وجه سياسي مقبول
وبنيامين نتنياهو لاخجل من انه يظهر معه
في الصور وكتب مقاله في سبع نوفمبر الماضي
وقال اصدقائي اعطوني فرصه من فضلكم يخصهم
الدنيا فرصه انا نطقت ودركت الى الحياه
اكثر تعقيدا وانا مستعد للعمل مع الجميع
وانا مش مؤمن بكل افكار مقادير كهانه لكن
رغم انه كتب هذا المقال بعدها بايام كان
واقف بدون مسدسه وفي القدس الشرقيه ويرغب
في اطلاق النار على العرب اللي يعني
مشتبكين معه بالحجاره وبيطلب من الشرطه ان
يردوا عليهم باطلاق النيران
وهو نفسه بعدها بعده ايام من هذا المقال
كتب تابينا باحتفاء بذكرى ماهير كاهان مره
اخرى وبيقول الناس فاهمها غلط ده رسالته
كلها كانت عن الحب وحب اسرائيل بالدرجه
الاولى واللي رد عليه المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه وقال له ان الاحتفاء
بقرث منظمه ارهابيه يا سيد بن غفير امر
بقيت ومخجل طيب
عموما همم بن غفير مش لوحده هو صديقه
بتسلائيل ساموتريتش اللي تولى وزاره
الماليه ومعه في نفس الائتلاف الصهيونيه
الدينيه برده بيشاركوا نفس الحماس لطرد
العرب واقامت المستوطنات في على على كل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه والعربيه
وهو نفسه اعتقل في سنه 2005
بالتحقيق معهم من قبل الشباب لانه وجدوا
معه كميه مفرقعات عباره عن كميه بنزين
وصولار كبيره جدا بيسعى لاستخدامها
لتفجيرات لاعاقه اخلاء المستوطنات في غزه
لما ايريل شارون اراد اخلاقها في 2005
وبيعتبر ده خيانه لمملكه ودوله اسرائيل
وعنده تصوراته هو شايف انه الحياه سوف
تستقيم في اسرائيل اذا اقمنا الشرائع لها
وديها كما يفهمها ولذلك كان من ضمن اشدته
انه يزود مخصصات
المدارس الدينيه لما سالوه ليه بتزود
الصحفيين الاسرائيليين بتزود ليه مخصصات
المدارس الدينيه دول ناس من العلمانيين ما
بيحبهمش دول ناس عاوزين يوصلوا ويصوموا ما
يخدموش في الجيش الاسرائيلي واحنا نتعب
ونديهم ضرائبنا فيحضوا بامتيازات فقال لهم
ببساطه لان انا رجل قوموا بالتوراه هذا ما
جاء في التوراه وكلما اهتمامنا بالتوراه
كلما كانت حياتنا افضل ورد على الصحفيين
وقال لهم بايه اذا حفظت وصيايا وقمت بها
فساعطيك المطر في موسمه وسوف يكون هناك
رخاء عظيم فما تسالنيش عن قواعد الماليه
العامه وعجز الموازنه اسالني عن البركه
التي سوف تحصلون عليها باهتمامنا بالتوراه
اقفي ما عاوز نفس القصه عنده افكار مشابهه
لكن الغرب مركز على ابي معاذ لانه اكثر
هؤلاء المتشددين هجوما على المثليين
الجنسيين ودي مساله بتزعل قوي الدول
الغربيه على العموم التلاته دول افكارهم
قريبه بس بشكل ذاعق من افكار نفتلي بنت
اللي مسك رئيس وزراء لفتره قصيره واللي
لما كان صحفي بيساله انتم مصرين على وضع
يدكم على اراضي محتله في الضفه الغربيه
فنفى ان تكون الاراضي المحتله في الغربيه
اراضي محتله وقال له هي اراضي يهوديه بحكم
ما جاء في التوراه عاوز تغير وضعها الان
غير ما جاء في التوراه ما يعني انه بيحتكم
في سياسته الداخليه في رؤيته للامور مش
لاي اتفاقات دوليه ولا امم متحده ولا مجلس
امن ولا اي اتفاقات مع اي دول ولكن الى ما
جاء في التوراه وكيف يفس للتوراه وهذا امر
بالغ الخطوره
الكلام ده كله بيثير القلق على كل
المستويات اول مستوى الان طبعا هو
الاسرائيليين نفسهم الاسرائيليين شايفين
الجيش الان لان هذا يعني انه بيتم تحميشه
وقد يورثه في الحروب اللي يرغب فيها
الشرطه قلقانه اعتدت ان تكون مستقله وترى
نفسها الان خاضعه للمستوطن متطرف
القضاء يشعر بانه ان في نهايه المضاف
التغييرات دي بتستهدفه همم وتضع فيها هو
في في فوهات المدفع وتريد السيطره عليه من
قبل سياسيين المتطرفين اليمنيين اليمنيين
العلمانيين الاسرائيليين بيشعروا بالحسره
وبيعتقدوا وفقا لتعبير اكثر من سياسي منهم
رئيس الوزراء السابق هير اللي بيقول ان
هذا انقلاب واضح على انقلاب سياسي واضح
يعني على الحياه السياسيه الاسرائيليه
وتاثيرات سوف تكون بالغه الخطوره فالجميع
الان
معنى من اسرائيل هذا شانهم ودعنا من
الفلسطينيين لان بديه انه قلق الفلسطينيين
اكثر من قلق اي شعب اخر لانه اراضيهم
ارزقهم اماكنهم الدينيه حياتهم اولادهم في
مهب الريح ده امر معروف مش دعم منه لانه
قليل الشان ولكن لانه واضح جدا وبدات
الاختيارات تتوالى على الفلسطينيين باخلاء
بعض الاحياء وبداوا بالف فلسطين باخلاقهم
من منطقه اظن اسمها مسافر يطا اذا ما كنتش
اخطات في الاسم يعني في الايام القليله
الماضيه انما كمان القلق بيذهب الى الغرب
الدول الغربيه تشعر بالقلق والخجل
والاحراج حليفتها الاساسيه اسرائيل بتتحول
الى نظام يشبه النظام اللي هم بيسخروهم
منه في ايران ما الفرق بين ايران اللي
بيسخروا منها وبيقولوا انها تحت حكم
مجموعه من الملائق المتطرفين وبين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اللي هي تحت حكم مجموعه من
الح او ممثلي الحاخامات اليهود ده واحد
اثنين ان الفعل ان الحياه في اسرائيل جزء
من
الحياه في اسرائيل بتتغير وجزء من الصوره
البرقه اللي كان الغرب بيفخر بها ان
اسرائيل دوله ديمقراطيه في محيط بالغ
التخلف ديمقراطيه وانه اسرائيل دوله قانون
ان في فصل في السلطات وان في حريه اعلام
وان في حقوق انسان وانه المراه بتحظى بوضع
استثنائي كل هذا يتغير الان ويصيب الغرب
بالخجل والاحراج وخصوصا انصار اسرائيل
القلق ايضا موجود اكثر في الشرق لانه
شايفين ان الوضع بهذا الشكل سوف يؤدي الى
انفجار الوضع داخل الاراضي المحتله
وانفجارها سوف يجر الجميع الى هذا الاتون
لان الدول العربيه لا تستطيع ان تقف
مكتوفه الايدي او على الحياه لوقت طويل او
على الاقل لن تستطيع مواصله العلاقه
الدافئه مع اسرائيل ولن تستطيع الحفاظ على
حراره الاتفاقات الابراهيميه كما حدث في
شهور الماضيه لن ي- لا يمكن ابدا تسويق
السلام مع مزيد مع العرب وهم حكومه يعني
محكومه بهذه المجموعات بالغه التطرف دينيا
وقوميا وبالتالي حتى يعني في اضعف الاحوال
سوف يكون هناك توتر يحرج الدول العربيه
والاحراج سوف يزيد لانه هذه الاوضاع بتعزز
صوره ايران باعتبارها الدوله الاعلى صوتا
في انتقاد اسرائيل وفي الدفاع عن حقوق
الفلسطينيين ده بيحرق كل الدول العربيه
على وجه اليقين ولكن هذا اضع في الايمان
لكن ممكن ان يكون الامر اسوء وتنجري
المنطقه الى
حروب ومواجهات المجموعات المتطرفه ديت لا
تستبعد ابدا ان تاخذ اسرائيل في مغامرات
ضد ايران في لبنان ضد اي دوله عربيه اخرى
والاخطر من كل ذلك ان حكومه بهذه التركيبه
سوف ترفع درجه التطرف في المنطقه لمستويات
غير مسبوقه الشرق الاوسط كله غارق في
التطرف اخر ما يحتاجه حكومه يهوديه بيحلم
مسؤوليها كل يوم بتحقيق النبوءات
الثوراتيه كما يفهمونها ودفع العالم دفعا
لحرب نهايه العالم اذا كنت انت كيهودي مصر
على ان تحتكم لتفسيرك للتوراه في اداره
شؤونك الداخليه والخارجيه مع العالم الاخر
وفقا لهذه الرؤيا وهذه التفسيرات
التوراتيه الذي يمنع المسلمين
ان يحتكم الى ما يعتقدون انه الفهم الصحيح
للقران والسنه ولماذا نصفهم بانهم متطرفين
ما الذي يمنع المسيحيين من نفس الحق وتصبح
المنطقه باكملها غارقه في حروب دينيه
مدمره لا تنتهي انا قلت لحضراتكم اللي
بيحصل في اسرائيل وفير للقلق وبينت ليه
ومثير للفضول ومثير للتامل ايضا لانه في
جوهره مثال رائع على مدى تاثير مصالح
النخب في توجيه السياسات الداخليه
والخارجيه كل اللي بيحصل في اسرائيل ده
وكل اللي ممكن ينتج عنه داخليا وخارجيا في
القلب منه حمايه مصالح شخصيه سياسيه نافذه
مصالح النقب عاوز تفهم سياسات الدول وليه
بتتحرك لازم تفهم مجموعه من الامور امنها
القومي جغرافيتها اقتصادها ومصالح النخل
فيها وفي حاله اسرائيل مصلحه نتنياهو التي
اجل حمايتها هو مستعد في اشعال النار في
اسرائيل وفي كامل منطقه الشرق الاوسط ومعه
ان شاء الله يكون لنا حلقات نراقب فيها
الشان الاسرائيلي
وكيف يمكن ان يؤثر على كل ملفات المنطقه
اشكركم والى اللقاء